sabaha is very nervous as he waits for
the big news his wife is giving birth in
this clinic men are not allowed to enter
the pediatric ward it's one of the few
places pregnant women in northern Italy
can go after 10 hours of waiting the
moment has finally arrived Sabah's wife
has given birth to a boy
Mohammed the proud father can hardly
believe his luck he sends the first
snapshot of the newborn to all his
friends and relatives we came here to
northern Syria so my wife could safely
deliver her child I'll stay here until
tomorrow then we'll bring our baby to
our Hut but a bleak existence with no
prospects awaits the family there the
atma camp Enid liebe offers refuge to
800,000 people they come from across
Syria fleeing Assad's bombs now they're
stranded here in the country's last
rebel-held Enclave they have a vague
hope for some security there are
practically no jobs there's not enough
food water or medicine
Suba and his loved ones have already
lived in the camp for two years for
people in a simple room with tarps
there's no protection from the heat
his daughter suffers from bronchitis but
no one can help here they prefer to go
back home to Hamas but that's simply
impossible we can't go back because
there's permanent fighting bombing and
shooting whenever we tried to return
there were grenade attacks and barrel
bombs families from across it Lib hoped
to get a little help in the alaqah
clinic one of the few medical centers
that has not been destroyed by bombing
126 children are treated here every day
but the clinic has long been unable to
treat all of them it lacks doctors and
medicine newborns in particular are
quickly released and do not receive the
protection and the care they urgently
need
unfortunately the newborns often live in
tents and barracks instead of houses and
their parents often bring them back to
the clinic in very poor condition after
just a couple of days because their
living situation is so bad a faith
that's Abbas son Mahmoud could also
share his mother is still weak herself
after giving birth the newborn is
extremely vulnerable an uncertain future
awaits him in Syria's last rebel
stronghold